are you allowed to wear sunglasses in
jail only one guard present to release
an entire block of prisoners lone guard
investigates missing prisoner on his own
instead of calling in backup or sounding
alarm prisoner fakes hanging with entire
hallway and window behind him revealing
his trickery you look guard keeps
reading after letter opens with you
schmuck
also guy who hangs himself writes a note
that tips off that he's not really dead
and hopes this works but a single upward
blow should not knock a grown man out
walks out without making sure the guard
is unconscious also is he wearing street
clothes in prison also are there no
other guards anywhere that can stop this
escape attempt man porn gasoline outside
police station goes unnoticed no police
saw this escaping prisoner between his
cell and the front door
now when the for these guys during the
escape and why are they putting on their
clothes was it part of the plan to use a
gun to light the gas you're hoping it
will light on fire by shooting at it why
didn't you just bring matches or a Zippo
oh my they could never jump over that
fire it is way too high there's this
section here by the building that has no
fire and over on this side they could
just hurtle the railing and get to their
cars where's the cop coming from did the
cops put out a distress call in the last
10 seconds they are firing at them
during a high-speed pursuit through town
all character is important to the story
see the car chase happening so they
timed their escape to perfectly match
the starting gun of this random Beach
truck rally totally smoking all the
other cars that actually planned to win
this race or do you have evidence that
this is a little boys room except for
the Fingaz mask asthma cliche sweats
undershorts go into my bro's house
better brush my hair
Pepsi paid for two product placements in
the first 10 minutes of the film I guess
the rube goldberg gate opening machine
wasn't turned on when Corey Feldman
showed up if your gate opening Rube
Goldberg machine involves a chicken
laying an egg you can only have one
guest a day the gate could easily have
been opened by chunk just by reaching
over and unlatching it
Rosalita doesn't speak a word of English
how does a non Spanish speaking woman
hire non-english speaking maid how does
that conversation go pants and shirts
are in the second doesn't speak a word
of English so let's give her tons of
instructions on packing in English
leave it to a bunch of preteen boys to
think the penis is always supposed to
point up he
taking his third fucking asthma hit in
ten minutes he's brushing his hair again
every kid in this movie has one
repetitive indefinite business action
asthma kid has asthma suave kid is
always brushing his hair fat kid is
always eating and the Asian kid is
always Asian
your dad has bunches of pirate stuff in
the Attic at his house that you've lived
in for years and years and you've never
once been to the attic so basically this
attic is a Spencer Gifts 80s wander
music ye intruders beware I know he
knows Spanish but he's reading that from
that far away I can't even make out the
letters from this far away
actual historians let real treasure map
slip through fingers and end up in attic
storage and British think they blew up
the walls all around him the British
were not hanging around the Pacific
Northwest in the 1600s Chester copperpot
didn't find it how would we find it
because if Chester copperpot renowned
treasure hunter didn't find it no one
will grab the map oh yeah I might need
this little rock stone metal thing too
so I'll just grab that in case you can
give these papers to your father to read
through and sign official business and
home takeover papers are not delivered
in the rain to kids
376 lawn mower chops today for that well
it's not like letting the air out of
tires causes monetary damage to the
bicycle why would you buy this many
groceries the day before your house is
foreclosed on Steven Spielberg bike
fetish brand is a dictation kids on
bikes that just happen to be around when
he needs it furnace brand even going he
has no idea where Mikey and the others
went attempted murder how does he even
know to do this hey and that's a summer
place what's it doing open in the fall
this guy would be excellent at
cinemasins place where the kids need to
go to follow the map just happens to be
the same place where the prison escape
bad guys are hiding out these bullet
holes do not match the ones from earlier
that bran find these kids an odyssey not
have at least one broken bone from the
attempted murder hey where is he some
really scary look at that is he carrying
around a mirror just to make this joke
also how the fuck did the girls get here
they were in the car that through brand
off the cliff yeah Oh steep like there's
a hole these kids were having trouble
finding the secret entrance in the floor
so the filmmakers decided to help them
out local paper already has article
about the guy who broke out of prison
just a few hours after the escape also
there should be no apostrophe in
Fratellis some dead bodies must be
disposed of others can just be left in
the freezer I mean really like you into
let's cast you in a movie that's just
like that Oh data only problems battery
still left so long battery flashlights
last 10 seconds I can describe all three
of them chunk couldn't see this guy's
face even a little bit water fountain
trombone drinking these kids are strong
enough to pull on pipes oh that bathroom
fixtures get pulled out of the wall
isn't this supposed to be a secret
tunnel there had to be people in this
room recently too you know install the
pipes this would definitely kill him Lou
Gehrig Chester copperpot carried
baseball cards with him on his treasure
hunting adventures Rube Goldberg
underground killing machine the ropes
used in these booby traps survived over
350 years in these caves without rotting
away but the worst thing I ever done
they mix the father's fake puke at home
and then I wanted this movie theater the
bad guys have allowed chunk to talk for
a really long time about stupid that
doesn't have any bearing on the issue at
hand where do you get the coincidental
timing of the bats being released by
brand is the only reason chunk still has
a hand Oh Martin Sheen Marty gene that's
President Kennedy you idiot this kid is
more familiar with Martin Sheen than
John F Kennedy because these are
somebody else's wishes wishes don't come
true
asshole antagonists just happens to be
at the well with his bros just as The
Goonies are underneath it trio of
murderous villains whom we've only seen
disposing of dead bodies in this movie
decide to keep a 12 year-old witness
alive for some reason pirate movie
coincidentally playing on TV nice dig at
your ex but now you're gonna be freezing
cold being in captivity didn't make him
angry enough to rip the chains out of
the wall but missing out on that Baby
Ruth sure did magic asthma kid just
stumbles onto the stone ki think this
bowling ball on a track system would
surely have broken down sometime in the
last 350 years
shattering teeth are strong so are you
supposed to fall down this shaft to
continue following the map he fell
nearly died on the spikes and the next
time we see them everyone's down in this
new room
how did this happen these pipes should
not be moving
someone apparently put in a sound
effects CD right before the scene bran
you're shorter than normal but okay I'm
gonna kiss you anyway
even if you were going to invent an oil
slick gizmo why would you put that oil
in your shoes but where's the sudden
surge of water coming from sure he's
lucky these girls found and joined the
Goonies back at the restaurant because
otherwise they would all die right here
and now in this bone piano room
there's water flowing freely throughout
this wooden ship and it hasn't sunk or
disintegrated yet
I like how they all died around this
table like they must have died in the
middle of a staff meeting mansion
protagonist brags to his vanquished foe
before actually succeeding yo how did
these people get in here did they all
climb down here in complete and total
silence enough Mikey
long enough cliche how did they get up
here The Goonies had to punch out a
wooden plank and climb up in here also
why are they dry bad guys just let this
kid do this but instead of shooting it
Oh No jump in the water that'll
definitely hurt and why only the girls
hands tied what in any of the guys get
their hands tied how did the booby trap
pull up the ship's anchor and collapse
the cave wall of a pharmacy come on
leave harmony Jenna King a pity so
shouldn't all these kids be in very big
trouble bad guys show up right on the
beach where all the cops waiting to
arrest them are racist subtitled you're
gonna live with me now what did he
consult anyone about this or just make a
judgment call okay the cops the media
everybody's parents but the fucking
foreclosure guys are also coincidentally
on this beach at this exact moment they
even brought the cleaning lady to the
beach you have no idea how much those
jewels are worth it is way premature to
be ripping up contracts and just
assuming these jewels are worth an
amount equal to a house how did the ship
turn who turned it
Cindy Lauper
anyway what did I care I wasn't asking
for anything and besides Jimmy was
making nice money with me through my
Pittsburgh connections still months
after the robbery they were finding
bodies all over what is that
this is CBS news live coverage of the
scene for vism Texas dan Rather with
Bruce hall as we continue to wait for
the next development which we believe
will be of Jessica McClure coming up and
out of ground why'd you catch that
because it was gonna fall your shirt
yeah but it didn't fall you caught it
gee
if and Latin Jehovah started
but rights we shouldn't even be here
it's like in the great stories mr.
fertile the ones that really matter
folk in those stories had lots of
chances of turning back only they did
they kept going you know what I would do
on the last day before my house got
foreclosed on and I had to move rather
than risking life and limb seeking out
some bullsh costume jewelry treasure
Hulu Plus I just binge watch my favorite
shows all damn day so pretty much like
any normal non foreclosure day if you go
to Hulu Plus calm slash sins and sign up
right now you could spend all day
watching on your laptop phone tablet or
even a wacky mobile device invention
created by data okay don't go home with
your potatoes sorry wrong cliche like
shark tank shark bait jerk bait Jimmy
Kimmel they got him live an active
social life and want TV content on your
schedule Jimmy I need go to Hulu Plus
comm slash sins today for a special
two-week trial offer just for our
viewers which should make you feel very
very special